hey guys dr. Burke here in this video I
want to share with you the two most
dangerous foods that you can consume now
you probably are thinking it's sugar
related or junk food but actually it is
corn and soy yeah did you realize that
corn and soy makes a 50-percent of the
crops that are grown in the u.s. yeah
it's incredible
an average person consumes 77 hundred
calories of their diet of these two
so-called healthy vegetables so corn and
soy make up 40% of your diet that's
incredible 93 percent of all the soy
grown in the US is GMO 85 percent of all
the corn grow in the u.s. is GML so what
is GMO it's an alteration of the food
it's an alteration in this case it's a
resistant to a certain herbicide called
which is a wheat killer called Roundup
Ready or glyphosate so in other words
when they grow corn and soy you can
spray this with this herbicide and they
won't die all the weeds die but they
don't die okay so you're getting a lot
more of this chemical so what are the
dangers well there's been some
suppressed
studies independent studies not by
Monsanto who actually owns this this
technology and they found that it causes
some serious problems in animals okay
animal studies because who wants to do
on human studies we're doing a human
study now with within your diet but the
point is that animal studies they found
that it creates all sorts of cancers of
the breast of the liver of the kidney of
the uterus okay of the ovaries yeah I
know so the problem is that the World
Health Organization only requires you to
do studies for 90 days three months okay
and if you pass the 90-day mark or
actually you get through it it's
considered safe yeah well right now
there's class-action suits I don't know
how far it's going to go because Obama
passed a law in the middle of night of
course that states that
Monsanto gets in trouble well they can't
sue them basically so they're not going
to really get in trouble because there's
a law that protects them unfortunately
and I'll put the link down below you can
check it out but here's the data on
glyphosate there's a lot of unknowns
right now but in the last 15 years
there's been a 3,000 increase in
exposure to this down pesticide okay and
this I'm sorry this herbicide and this
herbicide creates alterations in your
endocrine system it's considered an
endocrine disruptor and it acts like
estrogen and that's why it creates a lot
of cancer and other problems as well
allergies
probably autism and all sorts of things
okay so I'm just want to show you
something let's take a look at some of
the hidden foods okay what about ketchup
high fructose corn syrup what about all
the dressings with the soy oils and the
corn oils here's some hidden corn
products citric acid that's actually in
vitamin C confections sugar corn flour
corn fructose corn meal corn chips corn
syrup dextran dextrose fructose high
fructose corn syrup lactic acid malt
mono diglycerides MSG monosodium
glutamate sorbitol starch baking powders
and many synthetic vitamins okay that's
that's in corn now in soy bulking agents
carob emulsifiers gargle natural flavors
soy beverages all the weight like
leather weight-loss programs have soy
isolated protein type powders incredible
textured vegetable protein vegetable
broth I diet foods I mean there's over
3000 foods that have corn and soy okay
so the problem is we're in an experiment
right now we can't even know we're a
ting we're getting exposed to it's hard
to avoid it so you're going to have to
do three things okay number one you're
going to have to try to avoid this start
reading labels okay you're going to have
to
I put a link down below that you can
print out some hidden foods that you
need to start becoming aware of to avoid
as much soy in the corn as possible
until your friends your family and just
make sure they don't consume it
especially if you're at risk for breast
cancer or any type of cancer I mean
we're all at risk right number two make
sure as much as possible you start
eating organic why because if it's
organic corn or soy then that means it's
not GMO okay so that's one way so number
three you're going to have to start
consuming foods that deactivate some of
these I call them poisons in your liver
okay and so what you can do with that is
you start consuming a little bit of
cruciferous in the diet kale broccoli
brussel sprouts things like that that
will slowly start to protect you because
those are anti-cancer foods anti
estrogen ik foods okay so number one
avoid it
number two get organic number three eat
cruciferous foods that will deactivate
some of the stuff in the liver okay
alright so on that note on that fun note
go ahead leave your comments below and I
will see you in the next video